miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
send me home Hello friends I'm nazarez
and you're watching the big ticket
interview for Spider-Man across the
spider-verse I am so elated to be in the
presence of the three of you Miles
Morales represents so much to so many
different people and when I think of
like the upper echelon of superheroes
like Iron Man or Superman or Batman I'm
obsessed with them but they all look the
same and so I think because of your
characters and Miles Morales and really
these movies we're all really able to
see ourselves through Spider-Man which I
think is really special
um shamik I'm Dominican so Miles has
just meant the world you know he's an
afro-latino he lives in New York 28 of
New York City's population is Latino and
I know that you have roots from the
Caribbean so what was most exciting
about exploring miles's roots for you
and what of yourself did you contribute
to the character first and foremost I've
always been uh
fascinated with the uh with the language
just going out and about and I have a
lot of Hispanic friends uh from from
different walks so I I think when I when
I took on the role I was excited to to
get to play and learn as much as
possible but as far as what I added to
the role I mean
I really follow directions more than
anything I I put my
Spirit into what I take on in general so
Miles gets you know my
you know energy and spirit and and way
of like communicating through the
through the lines and whatnot but as far
as the cultural aspect of it you know
it's it's just um I'm I'm just thankful
to be useful to be used I just uh it's
it's 99 everything else and one percent
me you know well I gotta say because I
you know the first one and this one with
him shamik has a lot of heart and he's
got a lot of Style and what was wild in
working with him in the booth and then
seeing it is the animators captured that
so I think with a different actor you're
not getting miles the way we all fell in
love with Miles without him so that
style when that heart comes across this
is why I love this guy
and we all love the dynamic between both
your characters
um but yeah and it's what's really cool
too for me personally is that we're
getting another half Latino in
Spider-Man 2099 Miguel O'Hara played by
Oscar Isaac Irish Mexican feels like
he's really taking center stage in this
movie but I was reading that he's not
the villain but he is somewhat of an
antagonist to miles so I was curious how
each of your characters relate to
Spider-Man 2099
um let's start with shamik and go to
Jake and then end with Kaylee uh miles
he's just like you know what's up huh
you know what I mean he's like trying to
get he's trying to get you know accepted
by Miguel really and
I think he he finds heartbreak you know
uh Mina Miguel without without giving
too much away so yeah I think Miguel is
running the whole new spider community
and I think Peter likes the community I
think he wishes um Miguel was more like
the other spider people it had more of a
sense of humor about him was a little
bit lighter and was a little bit more
open but that's not who Miguel is but I
think Peter also and I think they all
see that like he's trying to help
so if you're trying to help the cause
you're on the team but Miguel's doing it
differently
yeah I would say um I guess Gwen sort of
Falls somewhere in between all of that
she is a part of that of of his spider
Society
um and is is there to report for Duty
and I think you know that on on the head
Gwen's sole purpose is to help people
and she will make sure she is everywhere
she is wherever she needs to be in order
to do just that and follow any orders
um as long as that's the the outcome
she's working towards I think the the
conflict for her there is her wanting
miles to be a part of that but also
believing in him and his ability to go
on his own and do his own thing
um so yeah well let's talk about Gwen
and Miles I love Gwen so much she to me
is just the coolest character this movie
opens up in her world there's a lot of
her world in it she's got a lot going on
I know director Kent Powers said that
when miles meets Gwen that she's not
wearing ballet shoes she's wearing
Converse Chuck Taylors that spider Punk
gave her so made me want to ask you
Haley did you I didn't know that DJ wait
really
that face he said where'd they come from
oh my goodness who gave them to you yeah
wow I'm feeling the tension already I
wanted to ask you what is the state of
Guile's in this movie and what happened
oh my God I feel like I'm just dropping
gems right now what is the state of
Guile's in this movie and what happens
you know when Hobie Brown AKA spider
Punk is added to the mix
well
why am I so like jealous right now talk
to us about it
I think Miles and Gwen are uh you know
exploring that energy you know they left
off on it's been a year and a half since
they saw each other and and Gwen is like
this cool girl that just came out of
thin air From Another Dimension and here
she is and oh wow but you've been
hanging out with who yeah you've been
able to see him huh no Haley what are
your thoughts I I have always felt like
there's this there's such a strong
uh bond between miles and Gwen that
cannot be broken
um that a year and a half can go by
however much time can go by and and when
they're in each other's presence they're
fully aware of each other's capabilities
and I just think there's there's
something so sweet about how Gwen views
miles
um she sees his greatness and and what
he's able to do uh which is again I
think a lot of the conflict here where
she wants to see him go and write his
own story as she knows she's in that
place in her life where it's time for
her to do the same this is a big this is
a big movie for Gwen too you know this
was uh in watching it it's really neat
this feels like Gwen was great in the
first one but this feels like a really
like big coming out party for her like
she's really like she's torn and she's
thinking about miles but she's also got
her own battle sure which is really nice
to see you know and like you're like oh
this is where Gwen becomes full you're
like oh okay Gwen's about to take over
yeah she's about to do some stuff yeah
yeah it's me yeah so miles is definitely
trying to impress Gwen
yeah well spider Punk's a musician right
and boy there's a drummer so there's a
lot for some reason I just feel like the
romance Arc in Spider-Man Just Hits
different do you guys feel that way like
I'm more invested in Spider-Man's
romantic life than any other superhero
I've always been that way since I was
little
um but I was reading that Issa Rae who
is Jessica Drew in this movie has also
been a fan of Spider-Man since she was
in the third grade what can you guys
tell us about her character like how
does Jessica Drew mesh with your
characters and is she funny like Issa
Rae oh I mean she's got the best energy
and banter uh I had the privilege of
doing a session with her uh and it's so
funny because when when we did the first
one I didn't even know that was a thing
until you and I were like sitting down
doing an interview and shamique was
talking about how you two had been
spending a bunch of time together you
were in the booth you were having a
great time and I was like
this whole thing by myself like so the
second time around I was like y'all
better put me in the booth with these
people uh and I was able to to do that
with Issa and um the relationship
between Gwen and Jessica Drew is is uh
so special I mean there is something
about her that she is inspired by uh
that she has not found in anyone else
um she is
just the most
epic and badass woman who comes flying
out of nowhere eight months pregnant uh
just kicking ass
um all the way around so she she's
amazing Issa is amazing and yeah she's
got she's got that energy that that
humor for sure she's definitely a big
addition to the team it's so rare that
we get to see a pregnant superhero on
the big screen so I am so excited for
that and just issa's addition to this
whole this whole spider verse but she's
not the only spider parental figure in
this movie Jake I know you have two twin
daughters at home it must have been
really fun to come back and play Peter B
Parker as a father now him and Mary Jane
have a kid named mayday I'm curious how
does Peter B Parker being a father now
change the dynamic between him and Miles
I think he appreciates miles more I
think miles in the first one was a bit
of a pain for him but somebody he saw
greatness in but it was like that
younger brother Vibe where you're like
man and you got to pull it together on
this and then I think in his own reality
he realized how much he enjoys that
younger generation and how great and
somebody coming up can be who's not like
him who's younger who sees the world
differently and I think he thought if I
had somebody half like that I wouldn't
mind them in my home all the time
and so I think for the first time he saw
himself as a possibility of going like
well I guess I could be a father and do
this and I think it's because of you
know getting to know miles I love that
is there Dynamics similar to the first
film in this one no it's different right
there's a little bit of it yeah I
haven't seen it yet oh yeah yeah okay so
you guys have seen it we've seen it yeah
we saw it together actually oh amazing
sorry man
oh no no what'd you get that's what
that's what she texted me want to see it
alone I was like sure wow
he's out
do not forward
he is out no the relationship is
definitely different you know miles is
kind of he's grown up a little bit more
he's uh kind of on his own kick and you
know Peter kept some stuff from him so I
think you'll I don't want to give
anything away but the relationship I I
think between them in the world of this
if it continues or how it continues
Peter's got some making up to do because
it was a violation of their trust
um and so the movie you know it's a
different Dynamic this year I can't wait
to see it because I love that dynamic
between them too it's really it's my
favorite recording it I would say From
miles's perspective it's like that's
that's my peter you know what I'm saying
that's that's Peter you know so I feel
like it it is but the the actual was
happening is challenging it you know but
uh that's right I feel the same was it
emotional recording together
come on guys you know it's really nice I
think it was really nice to do the first
one together and I know at least for me
yeah I I found Peter uh opposite his
miles yeah so I'd recorded with the
directors and Phil and Chris and
everyone and we were just like you know
we know a lot of times we don't get the
full scripts we're just getting scenes
right and I was like okay a Spider-Man
comic that's animation I don't get it
right and then in hearing how he was
doing miles instantly I was like okay I
know how to be Peter to him wow so it
was it just made it different I asked if
it was emotional because I know that
writer producer Chris Miller said he
compared this film to Star Wars The
Empire Strikes Back and he said this is
a very emotional movie that when you get
to the end of it you'll know that you
have to see the third one and he said
that the spot is the villain in the next
two and I love the spot the spot was in
the comics in the 80s if you watch the
90s animated series he was there uh
shamik I wanted to ask you why is the
spa not such a threat to the
spider-verse why is the spot such a
threat to the spider-verse I mean uh
this dude is opening up dimensional
portals in doing it for fun and having
bread fall out of it at the same time I
mean it's it's this guy
spot in miles are um meant for this
ultimate battle you know spots bread
miles is gluten I get it exactly
it does okay it does okay cool it's
actually correct look at that I love
that I cannot wait for that because I
love his powers and I can't wait to see
how his powers are animated in all the
different dimensions let's talk about
the spider versus best parts of these
films I know we're gonna get to see at
least six different ones in this movie
like Miguel's Nueva York Gwen's world
Spider-Man India's mom baton which I
cannot wait for tell me what your
favorite spider verse is in this film
and why let's just go down oh geez
Brooklyn there you go
uh I will say I mean look
I
I can't pick a favorite I just can't I
don't know that I I can't so um I'll
save everyone me trying to pick one but
I will say uh one of my very first
sessions is I couldn't even tell you how
long ago it was at this point
um they were giving me the sort of
rundown of of Gwen's world right and
they mentioned that it was going to they
compared it to a mood ring
um and it'll sort of change colors and
and and the feeling uh and the energy
will shift visually based on the emotion
um and I could not think of a better way
the minute I saw the first clip and the
crazy thing too I'm sure you guys have
heard this too with like Lorna Miller
and even chem Everyone is always like
any time we're shown any little
30 second clip it's not finished it's
not lit it's not it's everything so many
things have to be done and I swear I'm
like if you guys didn't say anything I
would think this is it's like Perfection
every step of the way and seeing the the
um final product of of Gwen's world it
is truly breathtaking along with every
other uh world that we are able to to
see in this film no they're so visually
striking Jake you've seen it so you've
got to have a favorite Glenn's world's
really cool you're right about I didn't
realize that a mood ring thing now makes
so much sense
because the colors do change as you're
watching it and everything in this movie
The animation's so wild it's like
pushing so many boundaries that at times
I'm just kind of like what are they
doing now right like the Lego world was
really neat do you remember where it
like jumps into a Lego Universe for a
little bit and I'm like man what is
happening yeah so yeah yeah I mean
there's there's too much you got to kind
of see it but like there's it's kind of
there's too much to pick a favorite I'm
so excited
I also cannot wait for just the spider
people that we get to meet I remember
when I saw the first one I was like
spider ham is a Vibe and I don't know
why but he like popped up in my dreams
after oh it's a character
not in a weird way it just like stayed
with me after you know like I was like
that's so cool like that was so creative
who's your favorite spider person in
this movie and why maybe we'll start
with Jake and come back this way I like
uh Karen Sony's uh he's now in it it's
nice to see I've worked with him along
tamago is good to see his new character
in the mix uh I liked uh I like the
horse with there's a there's a horse in
it but you got to see it I mean there's
too many to give away so okay those two
Haley you laughed when he said horse I
know I was thinking the same
um yeah that was gonna be my answer
spider horse yeah it's fun yeah a little
bit Yeah but but yeah like Jake said
there's two there's too many to give
away they're a lot of options for some
faves
it's all right Jimmy yeah you know I'm
probably just gonna stick with uh with
with Gwen's character
had a pair of Converse to buy after this
that's so incredible thank you for your
time and this verse in this reality and
thank you for putting your art into
these movies uh because we all really
see ourselves through them and my
friends thank you guys so much for
watching Spider-Man across the spider
verse tickets are on sale right now on
fandango.com my name is Naz Perez and
spider ham really did pop up in my dream
thank you guys thank you